Cadmium?
Yes
Ok
Oh yeah, that’s some! That is cool man!
So cadmium is an element which is really quite
similar to
mercury and the way that most people have
seen cadmium is
that cadmium sulphide has a very strong orange
colour and it
is therefore used for dying things yellow
or orange. If you
look round your house or your parents’ house,
you may easily
find a cast iron pot which has, a cooking
pot, which has nice
orange sides and orange lid and this is using
cadmium
sulphide as a glaze.
So this is a sample which was generated or
which was used
by some of our researchers in the School of
Chemistry many
years ago and this is a sample of cadmium
metal. Now it’s
very interesting because it is stored in this
really quite nice
box which was perhaps a medication that somebody
had
bought, but if we open it…
It's also I believe, to colour the plastic
pipe that you see in
the street for gas pipes and so on. I think
it is coloured with a
cadmium compound. Now in both these applications,
even
though that cadmium is quite poisonous, that
they are so
strongly fixed into the materials that it
isn’t a threat to
people.
And we can see the lumps of the metallic cadmium.
Now I am
not going to touch the cadmium because we
know of some of
the issues with toxicity. But it is used very
often in batteries,
or it was traditionally used in batteries.
It is really important
that we dispose of our batteries in a correct
way.